المترجم: Fadia Moubarak
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
(تصفيق)
مرحباً،
أنا مهند أبو رزق، مخرج وكاتب أفلام أردني،
طبعاً هنالك أشخاص يقولون لي،
بقصد الاستهزاء،
هل يوجد أفلام أردنية
حتى يكون هناك مخرجين أصلاً؟
ولكن أنا موجود في هذا الكوكب معكم،
وبصنع أفلام أردنية،
ومنذ بداية صناعتي للأفلام الأردنية
هناك تعليق اسمعه كثيراً،
يا عمي الأفلام هذه شغلة كماليات،
لماذا بالضرورة
أن يكون هنالك أفلام في حياتنا؟
لماذا يجب علينا نحن كدولة أن نضع وقت، جهد
ومال لنقوم بصناعة الأفلام؟
هل فعلياً ليس بالضرورة أن يكون لدينا
أفلام أردنية؟
سوف ابدأ بسؤال، كم شخص هنا
يعرفُ مصطلحات تركية؟
(صورة)
أتخيل أن جميع الفتيات سيرفعن أيديهن.
(ضحك)
كم شخص هنا يعرف نهفات مصرية؟
أو التي يسمونها الفيهات
أغلبنا يعرفها ويستعملها في حياته اليومية،
وأتخيل أن أغلبنا يسمع جملة
عندما يرى هذه الصورة،
(صورة)
(ضحك)
الحكمة المعروفة، "البيت ده طاهر ورح يفضل
طول عمره طاهر."
لماذا تتخيلون أن هذه المعلومات وصلتنا؟
وصلتنا لأنه باختصار العالم يتناقل أفكاره
وثقافته من خلال فنونه.
طبعاً غير معرفتنا بالرقصات الهندية،
أو بأسلوب الحياة الأمريكي بكامل تفاصيله.
هذا العالم يتتناقل أفكاره وثقافته
من خلال فنونه،
ومن أهم الفنون لتوصيل هذه المعلومات
هو الأفلام.
لماذا الأفلام؟
لأن الأفلام باختصار هي من الفنون القليلة
اللتي تستعمل الأسلوب السمعي والبصري
في توصيل المعلومات.
يمكن أن تقولوا لي حسناً، أي فائدة معنوية،
وثقافتنا تنتشر،
ولكن ليست بفائدة ملموسة في حياتنا اليومية.
ما هو رأيكم لو أخبركم أن للأفلام
دور في نمو اقتصادات دول.
في احصائية نشرتها TCI Research
أخبرتنا أن واحد من أصل عشر سياح
يذهب إلى كولومبيا، لأنه تأثر بشكل مباشر
بمسلسل ناركوس،
(تصفيق)
(صورة)
وغيره من المسلسلات اللتي تعرض أيضاً
كولومبيا بأعمالها،
هنا المسلسل يعرض كولومبيا، يُأثر
على السياحة في تلك الدولة،
وبالتالي كان يُأثر على اقتصادها
حتى لو بشكل غير مباشر.
للأفلام دور تاريخي، كيف ذلك؟
الأفلام يُمكن أن تعتبر مرجعية
لبعض الحقب الزمنية.
لو نأخد مصر كمثال، لو أُريد أن أتعرف على
مصر منذ خمسين سنة، كيف كانوا يعيشون؟
كيف كانوا يأكلون؟ يشربون؟
وما هي المصطلحات التي كانوا يستعملوها،
وما هي المشاكل اللتي يعانوا منها،
وما هي الحلول التي يستعملوها
ليعالجوا هذه المشاكل؟
واحدة من المراجع التي يمكن أستعملها
هي أفلامها،
خاصةً الأفلام التي تم تصويرها في تلك
الحقبة الزمنية
وتعرض تلك الحقبة الزمنية.
(صورة)
هنا بصراحة يخطر لي تساؤل، لنفكر به
معاً، لو شخص بعد خمسين سنة من اليوم،
جاء ليعرف الأردن بعام 2018 كيف كانت
معيشتهم وكيف كانت حياتنا؟
هل يجد أي مرجعية مصورة من مسلسلات
أو أفلام بتعكس حياتنا؟
لا أدري، لكنه تساؤل جميل أن نفكر فيه.
الآن أنا شخصياً أكثر الأشياء التي تجعلني
أتحمس لأصنع فلم،
هو أن يكون يناقش القضايا الحساسة
في حياتنا،
القضايا التي تستحق أن تضعها أمام
المشاهدين،
وتخبرهم لنفكر بحلول لهذه المشكلة.
قضايا يمكن أن تواجهنا على مستوى البيت،
أو على مستوى الدولة،
أو على مستوى العالم كله.
واحد من الأمثلة اللتي أحبها كثيراً على هذا
الموضوع هو فلم بلود دايموند.
فلم بلود دايموند،
هو فلم إنتاج عام 2006 بهوليود،
هذا الفلم بطولة ليناردو ديكابريو.
(صورة)
الفلم كان يحكي قضية استخراج الألماس
والأحجار الكريمة
في بعض المناطق الفقيرة بأفريقيا.
للذين لم يشاهدوا الفلم كان يفضح مشكلة
كيف أن هذا الاستخراج للأحجار كان يسبب فقر
وعمالة أطفال، وقتل لأبرياء، وإنشاء جماعات
مسلحة، وغيرها من المشاكل في تلك الدول.
شركات الألماس الكبرى في العالم عندما عرفت
عن إنتاج هذا الفلم، قامت بحملة إعلامية
بالتعاون مع مجلس الألماس العالمي
قامت بحملة اعلامية قيمتها 15 مليون دولار.
الهدف من الحملة تحسين صورة الألماس،
كانوا على علم أنه بمجرد نزول هذا الفلم
في دوور العرض،
ويفضح أساليب استخراج الألماس في بعض الدول،
كانت سوف تضر مبيعاتهم بشكل كبير.
تخيلوا معي كيف لفلم أن يخيف شركات كبرى،
يخيف دول أو أفكار ناس
ويعمل على تغيير مسار قضايا.
لذلك ما هو دور الأردن في هذا المجال؟
هذه صورة لأول فلم أردني تم إنتاجه في
الخمسينيات كان اسمه صراع في جرش.
(صورة)
سألت صديقي المختص في السينما الأردنية
يعمل في الهيئة الملكية للأفلام،
قلت له، كم فلم أردني تم إنتاجه منذ
الخمسينيات إلى اليوم 2018؟
كم بتتخيلوا الرقم؟ 100؟ 200؟ 300؟
قال لي تم إنتاج ما لا يزيد عن 25 فلم فقط.
هل بإمكانكم أن تتخيلوا الرقم؟
لنضعه في سياق، مصر مثلاً أنتجت هذا العدد
خلال أقل من ثلاث سنوات،
هذه ليست مقارنة عادلة مع مصر لأنها
في النهاية دولة رائدة في هذا المجال،
ولكن يعطينا مؤشر كيف يتغير العالم.
الأردن تنتج مسلسلات، نعم، لها نسب مشاهدة
ممتازة جداً خاصةً في دول الخليج
ولكن أغلب المسلسلات الأردنية لها طابع
بدوي، وهذا ليس سلبياً بالضرورة،
(صورة)
نحن نعتز بالثقافة البدوية
ونعلم أنها موجودة في ثقافتنا،
ونرى أنه من الضروري
أن يكون هناك أعمال بدوية،
ونضعها أمام المشاهدين وفي الشاشات
وفي مسلسلاتنا وأفلامنا،
ولكن جميعنا مدركين أن ثقافتنا
ليست بدوية فقط،
يوجد العديد من القصص تستحق أن تروى
من جميع المحافظات ومن العاصمة،
هناك أشخاص سيقولون لي أن كلامك شاعري،
لأنك تخبرنا أن نقوم بعمل أعمال أردنية،
نحن غير مستعدين، هل كلامهم صحيح؟ لا أدري
ولكن هوليوود هي التي تجيب عن هذا السؤال،
هوليوود تقريباً كل سنة تنتج أعمالها
أو أجزاء من أعمالها هنا في الأردن،
يمكن أن تكون قد شاهدت هذا الفلم ولا تدري
أن هذا الفلم تم تصويره في الأردن،
ومن هذه الأفلام The Marchen
The Hurt Locker، Ala Aldin، Star Wars
Transformers وغيرها
من الأفلام المقدرة عالمياً،
(صورة)
هي الأفلام تم تصويرها في الأردن، غير طبعاً
الإنتاجات الشرق آسيوية والأوروبية،
كان إنتاجها يتم في الأردن لأن الشركات
الكبرى علمت أن الأردن تحتوي على مواقع خصبة
للتصوير، من إمكانيات، وكوادر، لوجود كوادر
أردنية تعمل على هذه الأفلام، ومن تسهيلات،
العالم بلش يستثمر الأردن
ونحن لا زلنا لم نفعل.
ما هو دورنا؟ وماذا علينا أن نفعل؟
سوف أتكلم عن نفسي، أنا مؤسس سيرة للأفلام،
سيرة للأفلام، هي حركة هدفها تحريك عجلة
الأفلام الأردنية،
وهذه صورة لشباب الفريق.
(صورة)
هنالك أشخاص منهم الآن هنا، تحية لهم.
(تصفيق)
هكذا أكون ضمنت عشاء الليلة على حسابهم.
(ضحك)
هدفنا في سيرة أن نبدأ بإنتاج هذه الأعمال،
أن نُخبر العالم عم قصصنا في الأردن،
وللبداية في هذا الطريق قمنا بالتفكير
أن البداية يجب أن تكون عند المشاهدين،
يجب أن نصل لأكبر عدد ممكن من المشاهدين،
ولذلك توجهنا للمنصات على الإنترنت
لن أتكلم عن سيرة كثيراً، سوف أعرض لكم جزء
من أعمالنا حتى الآن، تفضلوا.
(أغنية)
[سيرة للأفلام]
أُحب هذه الأغنية، تُشبهني، أنا تماماً
كالتي تقرأ الفنجان،
[يوم.]
ولكن الفرق أنني أنا اقرأ العيون،
عيون الركاب،
وهذا أكثر شيء يُذهب مللي،
صويلح صويلح، إلى صويلح يا صبية؟
هيا إلى الباص، هيا.
أنا يا سيدي كنترول هذا الباص،
ادفعوا الأجرة يا شباب، الأجرة إذا سمحتم،
ولكنني أملك مهارات كثيرة،
وليس فقط تجميع المال،
في كل صباح، أسرح في الأشخاص الصاعدين
والأشخاص الهابطين،
أُقلب أشكال ألوان،
ولكن هناك شبه واحد بينهم، هل تصدق؟
أغلب الأشخاص الذين يصعدون غيرُ مقتنعين
بالمحطات التي سوف يهبطون عندها،
لو سمحتم يا شباب أن تعودوا للخلف، تمسك
بماسورة الباص،
الأشخاص هم نفسهم، لقد حفظتهم،
هذا الشاب مثلاً،
يعمل كمحاسب،
أستطيع أن أعرف من حقيبته
وملفات الضريبة داخلها،
ولكنني أستطيع الجزم
أنه يتمنى أن يصبح مصور،
نعم، أستطيع المعرفة
من خلال طريقة إمساكه لهاتفه،
يتمنى يومياً أن ينزل في محطة الشاب الآخر،
مع أن الآخر هذا ليس سعيداً أيضا في عمله،
بيني وبينك أنه على حق، لم يعرف أحدٌ قيمته،
ويتمنى أن ينزل في المحطة اللاحقة،
أبو حميد، لو سمحت أن تُجلسَ هذه الصبية
أعانك الله،
حزين هذا الشخص، دائماً يكون هو الضحية،
حتى هذه الصبية، تتمنى أن لا تكون هنا
أصلاً،
يا رجل،
أُقسم لك أنهم مُضحكون ومُحزنون
في نفس الوقت،
كل شخصٍ منهم ينزل في محطة لا يُريدها،
ويتمنى محطةً غيرها،
والشخص الثاني يتمنى محطة الثالث، وهلم جرا.
أما أنا، فليس لي محطة.
[فكرة وتصوير ومونتاج وإخراج
مهند أبو رزق]
(تصفيق)
شكراً.
[سيرة للأفلام]
(أغنية)
"وحدات وحدات"
دعني أخبرك أمراً،
[يوم.]
لم أتخيل يوماً أن أكون هنا،
لماذا؟
لأنني لا أستطيع التعبير،
ولم أكن شخصاً ذكياً
في حصص التعبير وامتحاناتها
لم أكد أنجح في آخر امتحان لي،
ربما حصلت فيه على علامة 52%
هذا ليس موضوعنا، المهم أنني أنا هنا
وأنا الآن أُعبر،
هذا الشارع،
بالمناسبة أنا أحفظه،
أعبر خلاله يومياً،
لكن اليوم منظره مختلف،
كل شيءٍ هنا في هذه اللحظة مختلف،
رائحة الهواء،
طعم الماء،
أصوات الأشخاص،
حتى أشعر أنني أنا مختلف،
"سلمية سلمية"
هل تعلم؟
مع أن صوتي قد ذهب،
ولكنني فرِح،
أظن أن هذه المرة الأولى التي يذهب شيء مني
وأفرح.
"نبلغ السما نبلغ السما موطني موطني"
[فكرة وتصوير ومونتاج وإخراج
مهند أبو رزق]
(تصفيق)
شكراً شكراً.
من منكم شاهد هذه السلسلة
أو أي جزء منها؟
جميل جداً
(صورة)
هدفنا من هذه السلسلة بسيط جداً،
أن نروي نحن قصصنا،
هل يوجد أبسط من ذلك؟
الحمدلله، إلى الآن تمت مشاهدة هذه الأعمال
وغيرها على الإنترنت من قبل ملايين الأشخاص،
وتفاعل معها عشرات الآلاف، لتُبقي فينا ثقة
وأمل أن هذه الصناعة من الممكن أن تكبُر،
ثقة أن نخبر صانع المحتوى الأردني، اذهب
واصنع عمل وانشره وهناك من سوف يدعمك،
لو وجدوا محتوى يعبر عنهم وبجودة عالية،
أصبح لدينا الثقة لنخبر المشاهدين أن انظروا
إلى صناع المحتوى الأردنين،
يوجد لدينا صناع محتوى مبدعين، انظروا
إلى أعمالهم وقوموا بدعمهم،
ونحن لن نتوقف، هدفنا أن نصل للعالمية،
لما لا؟ لماذا أنت كشخص مستعد أن تشاهد
مسلسل أسباني مثلاً،
وأنت لا تجيد الأسبانية، من الممكن أن
تشاهد مسلسل تركي وأنت لا تجيد التركية،
أو باللغة الانجليزية وأنت ضعيف بها،
لما لا؟
لماذا لا يوجد هذا الشخص بأي بقعة
في هذا العالم ليتابع فلم أو مسلسل أردني،
وأن يستمتع به وينشره، وأن لا نشعر أن هذا
شيء غريب،
بل على العكس أن يكون هذا هو الشيء الطبيعي،
دعوني أخبركم بشيء أُؤمن به، بنفس قدر
تعطشنا لنري العالم أعمالنا،
العالم خسر لعدم وجود أفلام أردنية،
ربما يظن البعض أن هذه جملةٌ مبالغٌ بها،
ولكن لا، أنا أؤمن بها، لأنه وباختصار
التراث الأردني تراث إنساني،
من حق العالم أن يعلم ما بهذه البقعة
من الأرض من قصص، وكيف هي حياتنا،
ولأجل ذلك يجب أن نصنع الأفلام،
أفلام تروي قصصنا، تعبر عنا،
أفلام تخبر العالم أننا موجودون، وهذا هو
الفن الخاص بنا، أفلام لتنشر وعي وتنمي فكر،
أفلام تساهم ولو بطريقة غير مباشرة
لنطور منطقتنا،
ولنفعل ذلك، من الصعب جداً أن نقوم بهذه
المسيرة لوحدنا، يجب أن نقوم بها مجتمعين،
ربما نجدُ أشخاصاً هنا في هذه القاعة
من أصحاب الفن،
فنانين أي أن يكون رسام، مغنية، شاعر،
أو صانع أفلام،
ربما لا تكون مما ذكر، ولكنك
تكون شخصاً متذوقاً للفن ويقوم بنشره،
يقوم بدعمه، أن نشترك سوياً لنجعل الأردن
تساهم في هذا الحوار العالمي الفنّي.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)